and we'll some something happened the
other day after we caught up Liz oh just
major fans go berserk but it was like
everywhere oh my gosh yes they got a
collab so now that I've brokered the
deal okay is it a done deal do you need
a broker spheres I mean I mean that's a
hustler if you did right I mean I would
not like to but I would have to respect
it if you granted that but um
Lizza was a beast yeah I said it before
us it again she's so refreshing to our
time and our culture and music and she's
everything that every woman wants to be
every woman wants to be a Liz oh and and
I think every woman actually has a
little deep down in there and she's
actually like validating that within
women and making them feel confident
which is everything I stand for so I
admire her a lot well you are incredible
woman yourself five years now for the
diamond ball congratulations thank you
so much what are you most proud of
accomplishing with your charity I'm
really proud of the fact that people
come back year after year I'm also
really proud of the fact that a lot of
we have a lot of newcomers every year
people that believe in it so it's just
not like the core foundation of people
that believe in the cause and the cause
is but there are people who fall in love
with what we're doing and they want to
join the team every year we have new
people showing up we have new buyers of
tables we have new performers who mend
their talents and their gifts I mean and
they don't have to they have so much
going on in their lives and I think that
says a lot about you I think it says a
lot about them because I can believe in
something but I cannot make any
leave in that and for them to give their
heart their gifts their life their day
their time their donations it means a
lot and it's something that cannot go uh
knowledged and you finally finally
you've given your fans little golden
eggs golden nuggets along the way often
times sometimes an Instagram what is
this are you hinting to everyone that
you're gonna be the new poison ivy and
Batman with one of your recent today yes
and I think oh don't you play this game
with me no I really want to know it's
it's something in one of your recent
Instagram post like Batmobile make these
that yes people are thinking really bad
oh yes people are going crazy
no that has doesn't do it poison ivy
sure that has to do a lot with Batman I
have separate obsessions I have a bigger
obsession with poison ivy I'm just being
honest yeah I dyed my hair red because
of uma Thurman there's no and I'm just
but you could be putting that out there
why nods you know what they didn't call
me it but if they did I would love to go
in and try out because poison ivy is
like one of my obsessions in life I did
it for Halloween one year I mean come on
so now you need to do it on the big
screen
I mean went on if it's not me it has to
be you
[Music]
[Music]